hi I'm Nick Gillespie with reason TV and
today we're talking with the makers of a
new documentary about world war two vets
it is called Honor Flight and we're
talking with clay Braga and dan hayes of
free think media guys thanks for talking
to us dan obviously you worked at reason
TV for a long time and honor flight
began I saw the first light of day as a
short documentary on reason TV what is
honor flight the documentary yeah so it
started in 2009 and went down to the
world war two memorial and I met a guy
named Theodore grows in ski was the
first veteran I interviewed and I just
asked him the question how's your day
going and he said I could die a happy
man now that I've made this trip and it
had a big impact on me and we went
throughout the day interviewed a bunch
of vets and they all said similar things
they all had very emotional reactions
and responses so that started this whole
journey but basically Honor Flight is a
program that sends world war two vets
out to DC to see the world war two
memorial and we followed the chapter in
milwaukee wisconsin for the last two
years and just kind of world war two
vets now are diving they're all pushing
80 or more right at least yeah most of
them are between i would say 85 and 90
some of them over 90 who made this trip
what are you know what what are their
stories are what what do they get out of
seeing a memorial I mean there's a lot
of discussion it took a while for the
memorial to get built even though it was
one of the older Wars you know why are
they happy to say it yeah I mean it took
60 years to build the memorial and I
think that it's just nice to give them
recognition for what they did and really
it's about the movie itself is really
about freedom and its most basic level I
think so in what way do you mean that I
mean thematically I think one of the
things as libertarians this might come
as a shocker or sometimes known as being
cynical or sarcastic but this is a
different take on freedom and what it
means to be free it's it's about the
emotion of freedom and sort of the
everyday nature of we live in the most
prosperous you know contrary ever with
the most opportunities we've ever had
and we need to take advantage of that
freedom that they provided for us the
premiere of the movie is going to be in
miller park where the Milwaukee Brewers
play you've sold 25,000
so you're hoping to push that closer to
thirty thousand and set a world record
why are you premiering it in you know a
baseball stadium yes so the trailer for
the film got four and a half million
views online through Facebook and that
to us was kind of shocking to be honest
with you and when that happened we
thought how can we continue to push and
be disruptive you know in the film
industry and with this movie and do
things in a different way and then this
opportunity came up to you know ran out
Miller Park Milwaukee Brewers Stadium
and it also was clear that there was
just huge demand for this film everyone
wants to be a part of it and the tickets
through you know advertising up there
through a radio show host who talks
about the event a lot online stuff they
just keep going up so yeah we're upwards
of twenty-five thousand tickets the
world record for largest film screening
ever is 27,000 and I think we've got a
good shot at breaking it what you guys
are you're young you're you know around
30 plus or minus and what is your
connection to World War 2 i'm older than
you my father dan and I have talked
about this my father fought in World War
two everybody I knew all my relatives
had fought in World War two and you know
but then what does it mean for the
Millennials are Generation X Y Z or
whatever you guys are now yeah i mean my
grandpa richard has fought at Okinawa I
never really talked about which any was
on the Allies which yeah he was he was
an ally he wasn't the Japanese yeah he
fought on ok now and I never heard his
story and I think that's one of the
things one of the lines in the film is
you know when you look at this plane
full of these old men and women older
men and women you know everybody sees
their dad so this this movie really has
become a story about people's families
so that's my direct connection but I
think more importantly for this
generation it's what I was saying
earlier it's meditating on what we
really have no and we can't take our
freedom for granted so how do we how do
we think about this on a daily basis and
in fact the Honor Flight slogan is every
day as a bonus and that's a phrase that
was coined by Joe demler who was
featured in life magazine as the human
skeleton in 1945 he was a poww in
Germany and when the reporter came up to
him
upon his liberation and said you know
what did you learn here Joe he said I've
learned to pray every day in a Nazi
prison camp and from here on out every
single day as a bonus and we think
that's just a really powerful message
message and one that would resonate with
the younger generation so to go back to
these questions of kind of disrupt the
ways of you know of doing film and what
not what is it like now you guys you
have free think media it's an
independent film production company do
work client work you also do creative
work is it is it easier is it hard to be
an independent filmmaker well I think
right now it's a really awesome time to
be an independent filmmaker you know we
started this company for you think media
with our own money and not that much of
it this film was made on a shoestring
budget and you're saying you've spent
about three hundred thousand dollars and
change yeah with you know labor our own
time and then expenses and stuff and
that's pretty low for you know something
like this and now when it comes to
marketing you know getting four and a
half million views through facebook
which is sort of unheard of for a
documentary and all the options out
there not just theatrical and TV which
are sort of the traditional avenues but
video on demand download to own
downloaded rent and a whole slew of
digital options we kind of have a broad
landscape of things in front of us that
we could do and it's pretty interesting
well thank you the film is Honor Flight
it's by directed by dan hayes produced
by clay Braga free think media the world
premiere is going to be in a gigantic
baseball stadium in milwaukee wisconsin
on august eleventh look for look for
that and get there if you can thanks
guys very much good luck with the
project for recent TV i'm nicholas
you